a new generation of Pokemon is upon us
and with it comes new Pocket Monsters
mechanics bad guys and if you're lucky
maybe an Eeveelution one can only hope
here's everything you need to know about
Pokemon scarlet and violet
[Music]
every new Mainline Pokemon game features
a new region and often these are based
Loosely on Real World locations the very
first Pokemon game for example took
place in the Kanto region which was
modeled after Nintendo and the Pokemon
company's home nation of Japan other
regions have been inspired by France
Hawaii and most recently the United
Kingdom the new region in Pokemon
scarlet and violet is paldea based
Loosely on Spain and the surrounding
regions that cultural influence shows in
several Pokemon names as well as
elements of the new cooking mechanics
based on released artwork the full map
appears to be very roughly the shape of
Spain
[Music]
foreign
and violet open world you can see wild
Pokemon wandering about just like in
Arceus and the wild areas of sword and
shield you can't simply catch a Pokemon
by tossing a ball in the open world
however but you can initiate a battle
that way for a bonus in a more marked
change from the norm you can even skip
battles altogether by having your own
Pokemon roam the landscape alongside you
passively picking up items and taking
care of enemy Pokemon and racking up a
reduced amount of experience the new
legendary Pokemon appear to serve as
mounts for navigating the open world
letting you Glide climb walls and run
faster also as a result of this open
world approach NPCs will no longer stop
you in your tracks to initiate a battle
instead you'll get a visual indicator
that they're interested in a trainer
battle and you can go up to them and
accept the challenge if you'd like
since the entire world is now
essentially made up of a wild area towns
are more of a safe haven from wild
Pokemon
[Music]
other than multiplayer being restricted
to a designated area like it was in
Pokemon sword and shield scarlet and
violet allows you to explore the world
with up to three other players for the
first time ever the two different
Pokemon versions will feature different
Pokemon professors Professor Sada and
Professor turo these two not only
represent different time periods with
sarda sporting a more historical look
and Toro a more futuristic fashion but
they both continue the recent tradition
of the Pokemon professor being a
certifiable hottie the game also
features a cooking minigame similar to
Arceus which lets you either buy
finished dishes or cook your own then
you can eat the foods either in town or
out in a field by setting up a picnic
these foods will give you passive Buffs
such as boosting your chances of finding
a particular Pokemon type for example as
you explore the game and put together
recipes you'll find some foods that can
help you catch specific Pokemon that
you're hunting for scarlet and violet
also introduce a new Pokemon power up to
raster forms these give your Pokemon a
crystalline look and enhance your moves
making them more powerful better yet you
can find rare to rational Pokemon that
can actually equip types outside of
their standard type classification this
will help you get a drop on opponents
who weren't expecting a type matchup
based on your Pokemon themselves and
should shake up the competitive metagame
it seems that these special terrestle
Pokemon will mostly be obtainable
through special events and raid battles
but any Pokemon species has the
potential to become a terastal form a
Pokemon's terrastal form will also
affect the power level of their attacks
if a Pokemon's Terror type matches their
base type then any move of that typing
gets a 2X boost if a Pokemon has a
terrastal type that differs from its
base type then any move of either typing
will get a 1.5 x boost for example
Pikachu an electric Pokemon with an
electric Terror typing will get a 2X
boost to any of its electric attacks
like thundershock however a Pikachu with
a flying Terror type will get a 1.5 x
boost to any electric or flying moves
that it knows so there are pros and cons
to both scenarios in the former
Pikachu's electric moves get a bigger
boost than if it had a different Terror
type but in the latter scenario Pikachu
has a more diverse range of attacks they
get a slightly smaller boost
foreign
with the new open world approach in
Pokemon scarlet and violet the linear
structure of past entries in the
franchise has changed as well instead of
a single story you can pursue one of
three major quest lines Victory Road the
path of Legends and Starfall Street
Victory Road is the most recognizable
and classic quest in Pokemon as you Vie
to be the very best like no one ever was
by conquering Regional gym leaders and
presumably the Elite Four this time you
can pick which order to challenge the
gym leaders which means that difficulty
balancing may be very different this
time in the one gym challenge we've seen
you didn't even battle a series of NPCs
in the game instead you play a brief
hide and seek game with some Pokemon and
then challenge the gym leader one-on-one
this could mean that gyms are more based
around themed activities rather than
battle gauntlets much like the trials of
Pokemon Sun and Moon the path of Legends
revolves around researching gargantuan
Pokemon known as Titans there are that
number of these massive Pokemon roaming
about and you'll need to follow the
clues to track them down and beat them
in battle for research purposes this may
be the path we know the least about
because even on our hands on preview we
were restricted from seeing the
conclusion of the battle against a
gigantic cloth
finally Starfall street is the new way
of challenging the new antagonist team
star these encounters are no longer
woven in and out of the story instead
team star has set up outposts of their
own and you'll need to enter a special
area to challenge them in our time with
the game the one team star challenge was
to take down a certain number of enemy
Pokemon within a time limit which then
led to battling the leader of that team
star Outpost
[Music]
scarlet and Violet's new starters are
sprigatito the grass cat Fue Coco the
fire Croc and quaxley the water duckling
we've only seen their starter forms so
we don't know how they'll evolve some of
the time as Pokemon evolve they gain new
types on top of their original Elemental
attributes subsequent trailers have
shown many more Pokemon including
favorites like Pikachu and Psyduck we've
also seen lots of new additions like the
cliff climbing crab cloth the Mega Man
looking bipedal amarouge and the
adorable Fido at to this point there are
way too many Pokemon to list in this
video so for more info be sure to check
out the link in the description and make
sure to subscribe to gamespot's YouTube
for a future video where we describe not
only the different Pokemon in skeleton
Violet but the other differences between
the two versions as well
as part of a new Gameplay trailer shared
in June it was revealed that Pokemon
scarlet and violet were released on
November 18 2022 exclusively for
Nintendo switch pre-orders for scarlet
and violet are now live Nintendo is also
producing a special edition Nintendo
switch that features the game's two
legendaries Corydon and miraidon on the
dock along with the school emblems on
the joy-con controllers for more details
on this special edition switch check out
our Pokemon scarlet and Violet's
pre-order guide in the link in the
description
[Music]